Speaker 1: Here's some interesting new polling
data since the draft from the Supreme Court
leaked, which revealed to us that unless something
changes, Roe v Wade will be overturned in the next
few weeks. Since that leaked support for abortion
rights in most or all cases has gone up to 60%,
which is the highest level in two decades,
according to a new NBC News poll. Let's look at
some comments about the polling from Mark Murray,
who's the senior political editor for NBC News.
Results from the poll. Abortion should be always
legal, say 37% of Americans legal most of the
time say 23% of Americans. So in total, 60% of
Americans believe that abortion should be always
or mostly legal. The combined 60% is the highest
percentage on this question, going all the way
back to 2003. Now, you might say, okay, but
hold on. Wait a second, David. Whoa, whoa, whoa.
The draft opinion from the Supreme Court
makes it just something states can decide.
So the polling doesn't really change
because you could be against Roe v Wade,
but still in favor of the state keeping abortion
legal. Okay. Well, the draft opinion would make
it legal for states to make abortion illegal.
And that's ultimately the same thing at the end
of the day. On the question from the poll, should
Roe v Wade be overturned? And this goes to that.
Only 30% believe that Roe v Wade should be
overturned. That is up from 23% in 2018. But 63%,
nearly two thirds of the country believe that
Roe v Wade should not be overturned. That is down
slightly from 2018. Now, there's another question
here. When we think about the political impact of
this forthcoming decision, we've been wondering
what will it do to the midterm elections? Will
it inspire Democrats and people on the left to
get out and vote for Democrats, by and large,
for independent voters? We know abortion is not
historically a big voting issue for independents,
but what might it do for voter turnout for
Democrats? We haven't had any new polling
that I've been able to find, unlike a generic
congressional ballot for November since the
Supreme Court decision leaked. It would be very
interesting to look at that data and hopefully we
will have it soon. The other part of this, by the
way, when we see 60% of Americans believe abortion
should be legal in most or all cases, that 60% is
not represented in the Senate. And as I've told
you before, the Senate is a fundamentally
anti-democratic body. You can have in the
Senate because every state gets two senators,
you can have 50% of the population I'm sorry,
you can have 50% of the Senate votes represented
by those who have only 17% of the population in
their states. That's extraordinarily lopsided
and undemocratic, and it's considered a feature,
not a bug of the Senate by many. So we're going
to continue following the numbers. But support
for abortions, legality up to record highs since
the leaked Supreme Court decision. And we'll have
more of that polling data on our Instagram. You
can find us on Instagram The David Pakman Show.